那么接下来 我们来讲一下关于标题的一个基本结构 我们现在讲的都是标题的一些概念 和它的一些误区 以及我们要做的一些比较结构化的一些标准去做标题 只有我们符合平台的规则才能够获得更大的流量 首先 结构化的优质标题有利于买家精准比配 好的标题是成本的标题
就是你写到了一个好的标题 或者是选到了一个好的产品 都会直接对你的后面产品的流量起着决定性的作用 以及你是否能够把这个产品打造成爆品 这个标题其实也起了非常关键的作用 首先第一个就是产品名称就是最大的关键词 一整个关键词集合 产品名称会直接影响你的产品曝光
产品的排名 因为产品名称就是由大量的关键词组合而形成的 这些关键词呢 搜索指数竞争程度 就会直接影响到这个产品的曝光 以及关键词的排名 其实就是对应着产品的排名 这标题呢 它又是搜索权重中最大的关键词 也就是在搜索
搜索产品的时候 第一匹配要素是先匹配标题的 如果你标题中都没有这些关键词 那么系统是不可能把你这个产品提取出来 拿去排名的
所以说标题必须含有客户搜索的这一类关键词之后 你才有机会参与排名 我们的基本的框架 一个标题的基本框架就是这一条公式
产品的标题 第一个就是营销词加属性词加产品中心词加使用场景 这是官方给的最简单的一个结构 但实际上呢 我们先把这个结构先了解了 后面我们还可以真正的去根据这个结构去衍生出更多的标题的组合方法 后面我们所说的那六种标题的组合方法 就不一定都根据这个逻辑去写了
所以我们至少能够先知道它的来龙去脉 然后再遵从它的一个规则去写我们的标题 就能够更加符合平台了 比如说产品标题 这个是产品标题 首先营销池就是高质量 就是营销池 属性词就是黑的 空白的 以及它的功能属性等等 这些都属于属性词 产品核心词就是你的产品词 比如说柜衣 T恤 杯子 刷子 牙膏
这些都叫做核心产品词 那么使用场景呢 一般来说 我们加个4 比如说
这个衣服是男是穿的 比如说有些它是场景 用于什么 用于什么 这种就是场景 用于什么 用于什么地方 或是谁用
这些都是属于一个使用场景 那么属性词的来源呢 我们主要就是一些产品的卖点 材质 特性 风格 季节性的一些
具体有搜索指数的关键词 一定要去选有搜索指数的关键词 因为如果是没有搜索指数的词
其实就是在平台上没有什么搜索的 那么你用了这些词在标题中
那么你是也很难获得流量的 因为都没有人搜 你用在多那种词也是没有任何的作用的
还有另外的一些就是流行的因素的词 比如说有些时候 比如说20
2023年 2024年 准备到了 那么他这种词 可能就会数据 会上涨 也就是有人在收这些 这些年限 或者是一些最近流行的一些风格的词 或者是最近流行的一些属性的产品的词 这些都是我们的一个属性词的来源 一定要记住这些东西 这个基本的标题的结构 那么